>>> ARMAGEDDON, A WORD YOU DO
NOT NORMALLY HEAR FROM A U.S.
PRESIDENT.
I'M JOHN BERMAN WITH BRIANNA
KEILAR.
OVERNIGHT PRESIDENT BIDEN WARNED
THAT THE WORLD COULD FACE
ARMAGEDDON IF VLADIMIR PUTIN
USES NUCLEAR WEAPONS AS RUSSIA
FACES SETBACKS IN UKRAINE.
THIS HAPPENED AT A DEMOCRATIC
FUND-RAISER THE PRESIDENT SAID,
QUOTE, WE HAVE NOT FACED THE
PROSPECT OF ARMAGEDDON SINCE
KENNEDY AND THE CUBAN MISSILE
CRISIS, I DON'T THINK THERE'S
ANYTHING AS THE ABILITY OF USING
A NUCLEAR TACT CAL WEAPON AND
NOT END UP WITH ARMAGEDDON.
>> THIS IS STARK LANGUAGE AND
COMES AS THE U.S. CONSIDERS HOW
TO RESPOND TO A RANGE OF
POTENTIAL SCENARIOS.
LET'S BRING IN WHITE HOUSE
CORRESPONDENT JEREMY DIAMOND FOR
MORE.
>> Reporter: U.S. OFFICIALS SAY
THERE'S BEEN NO CHANGE IN
RUSSIA'S NUCLEAR POSTURE.
ONE SENIOR U.S. OFFICIAL TELLING
CNN THAT THE U.S. DIDN'T DETECT
ANYTHING YESTERDAY THAT WOULD
INDICATE AN ESCALATION IN
RUSSIA'S NUCLEAR POSTURE, THAT'S
WHY IT'S STRIKING TO HEAR THE
LANGUAGE THAT PRESIDENT BIDEN
USED LAST NIGHT TALKING ABOUT
THE PROSPECT OF ARMAGEDDON
SHOULD PUTIN USE NUCLEAR WEAPONS
AND MAKING CLEAR HE DOESN'T
BELIEVE THE RUSSIAN LEADER IS
BLUFFING.
HERE'S A SNIPPET OF THE
PRESIDENT'S COMMENTS FROM THE
FUND-RAISER IN NEW YORK LAST
NIGHT, OFF CAMERA.
SAYING, QUOTE, WE HAVE A GUY I
KNOW FAIRLY WELL WITHIN HE'S NOT
JOKING WHEN HE TALKS ABOUT
POTENTIAL USE OF TACTICAL
NUCLEAR WEAPONS OR BIOLOGICAL OR
CHEMICAL WEAPONS BECAUSE HIS
MILITARY IS SIGNIFICANTLY UNDER
PERFORMING.
THAT IS ONE OF THE THINGS THE
PRESIDENT EXPRESSED THE MOST
CONCERN ABOUT IS WHAT IF PUTIN
DOESN'T HAVE AN OFF RAMP, WHAT
IF HE'S CORNERED?
WHAT DOES HE DO THEN?
NO QUESTION HE'S RATCHETING UP
THE RHETORIC ABOUT THE PROSPECT
OF NUCLEAR WAR, JUST LAST WEEK
TALKED ABOUT DEFENDING RUSSIAN
TERRITORY BY ALL MEANS
NECESSARY.
AND TALKED ABOUT A PRECEDENCE
THE U.S. SET USING NUCLEAR
WEAPONS IN WORLD WAR II.
BUT TALKING TO OFFICIALS THEY
SAID IT'S CLEAR THERE IS AN
ELEVATED RISK THAT RUSSIA COULD
USE A NUCLEAR WEAPON BUT IT'S
NOT EVEN PROPABLE AT THIS POINT
AND THEY HAVE NOT ASSESSED THAT
PUTIN HAS MADE A DECISION TO USE
A NUCLEAR WEAPON.
>> JEREMY DIAMOND, THANK YOU.
>>> WE WANT TO BRING IN CNN
POLITICAL AND NATIONAL SECURITY
ANALYST AND WHITE HOUSE NATIONAL
CORRESPONDENT DAVID SANGER.
ARMAGEDDON, DAVID.
HOW UNUSUAL IS THIS TYPE OF
LANGUAGE FROM A U.S. PRESIDENT
IN 2022?
AND WHY NOW?
>> WELL, JOHN, AS YOU AND JEREMY
BOTH POINTED OUT, IT'S HIGHLY
UNUSUAL.
I CAN'T RECALL A TIME THAT A
PRESIDENT HAS USED IT OTHER THAN
A HISTORICAL SENSE AND THAT'S
NOT WHAT PRESIDENT BIDEN WAS
DOING.
HE WAS BASICALLY WARNING THAT
ONE SHOULD NOT TAKE SOLACE IN
THE THOUGHT THAT IF PUTIN USES A
NUCLEAR WEAPON, IT WOULD BE A
TACTICAL OR BATTLEFIELD WEAPON,
THAT'S A SMALLER ONE THAT CAN BE
USED ON THE BATTLEFIELD.
AND THAT PRESUMABLY WOULD HAVE
SOMEWHAT LIMITED DAMAGE.
HE WAS BASICALLY SAYING IF HE
USES IT, THIS WILL ESCALATE.
I THINK THE SECOND REALLY
INTERESTING THING THAT HE DID
WAS TALK ABOUT OFF RAMPS AND THE
NEED FOR THAT IN THE SAME
PARAGRAPH HE TALKED ABOUT THE
CUBAN MISSILE CRISIS BECAUSE OF
COURSE THAT'S WHAT KENNEDY WAS
SEEKING DURING THE CUBAN MISSILE
CRISIS.
>> AND WHAT HE SAID -- OFTEN,
PRESIDENT BIDEN DOES THIS, HE
SORT OF OPENS THE DOOR TO
DISCUSSIONS THAT OFTEN HAPPEN
BEHIND CLOSED DOORS AND LETS US
IN.
HE SAID, BASICALLY, HE'S NOT
SURE WHAT THE OFF-RAMP IS FOR
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
>> THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT.
AND THAT'S WHAT I READ OUT OF
THIS AS WELL.
LOOK, THIS HAS BEEN A HUGE
SUBJECT WITHIN THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT.
I THINK MOST AMERICANS WHO HAVE
BEEN WATCHING UKRAINE AND
WATCHING THIS HORROR PLAY OUT
HAVE NOT BEEN AS FOCUSED AS THE
PRESIDENT'S ADVISERS HAVE BEEN
ON THE POSSIBILITY OF THE USE OF
A NUCLEAR WEAPON.
NOW, I DON'T THINK THAT
POSSIBILITY IS A VERY HIGH
CHANCE YET, BUT IT'S A LOT
HIGHER THAN IT WAS AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE WAR.
AND THAT'S WHAT HAS SO MANY OF
HIS ADVISERS CONCERNED.
THE PRESIDENT ELUDED TO THIS
HIMSELF, JOHN.
WHEN HE SAID THAT PUTIN IS NOT
PERFORMING WELL ON THE
BATTLEFIELD.
IN OTHER WORDS, HE'S SAYING HE
MAY HAVE NO OTHER OPTION TO SAVE
FACE AND THAT'S WHY HE WAS
LOOKING FOR THE OFF-RAMP.
IN THE CUBAN MISSILE CRISIS THE
WAY KENNEDY DID THIS WAS A
SECRET AGREEMENT TO REMOVE
AMERICAN MISSILES FROM TURKEY,
WHICH HAPPENED SIX MONTHS AFTER
THE CRISIS WAS OVER AND IT WAS
ALL DENIED AT THE TIME BY THE
GOVERNMENT THAT IT WAS PART OF
THE DEAL.
THE ISSUE IS WHAT'S THE ANALOG
HERE WHAT CAN YOU OFFER PUTIN
AND IF YOU DID, WOULD HE TAKE
IT?
>> IT'S VE